bienvenue à la facture voici l'histoire
d'une automobiliste qui a eu de gros
problèmes à la suite d'une erreur d'un
huissier tout le monde peut se tromper
mais dans ce cas-ci cette erreur nous a
permis de découvrir une pratique des
huissiers qui soulève de sérieuses
questions
infirmière à l'Institut de Cardiologie
de Montréal
elle habite à Laval et tous les jours
elle garde sa voiture dans les rues
autour de l'hôpital le 10 novembre
dernier une vilaine surprise latin j'ai
stationné exactement là où il y a la
voiture puis je suis allée travailler
juste sur la rue à côté donc je me suis
stationné ici puis le soir quand je suis
arrivée mais j'ai pas trouvé mon
véhicule je disparu j'ai tout de suite
pensé que je me l'était faite voler
j'étais juste sous le choc fait que j'ai
appelé tout de suite le 9 1
coup de chance une caméra de
surveillance ajustement capter la scène
des témoins rapportent qu'un huissier
serait derrière cette opération Clarissa
est stupéfaite ça se peut pas il y a pas
vérifier l'immatriculation il y a pas un
vrai huissier c'est ça que moi je
pensais et vous vous aviez pas de dettes
vous avez pas de raison d'être saisi non
pas du tout je suis tout en règle je
suis à jour dans mes paiements j'ai reçu
aucune aucune notice aucun avis d'un
huissier celui qui a saisi le véhicule
de Clarissa et bel et bien un huissier
Pierre-Yves portugais de l'affirme et
nos graveles et membre en règle de la
chambre des huissiers du Québec la
police confirme à Clarissa que c'est lui
qui a saisi sa voiture c'est là à ce
moment-là ça va prendre un avocat parce
que moi ça me dépasse là
or cette journée là non seulement
l'huissier est saisi physiquement la
mauvaise voiture ils la vend aussi sur
le champ c'est vrai que c'était possible
de juste saisir une voiture de la vente
puis jamais contacté le propriétaire
dans le dossier de cours lié à cette
saisie il est clairement indiqué que
Range Rover similaire à celle de
Clarissa est à saisir même marque même
modèle une voiture qui appartient à un
homme dont l'adresse de résidence se
trouve justement sur l'une des rues où
Clarissa garde sa voiture un homme en
défaut de paiement d'ailleurs en
remontant dans les archives de street
view on découvre une Range Rover noir
garée dans cette entrée à l'adresse même
de la personne à saisir nous montrons
cette image Street View à Clarissa ouais
c'est ça c'est pas mon véhicule sauf que
c'est une marque c'est la même marque
mais je veux dire on est des milliers de
personnes qui ont la même voiture plus
déroutant encore le numéro de série de
la Range Rover à saisir et bien indiqué
dans la vie d'exécution de jugement or
sur la vie de vente du véhicule on
constate que le numéro de série n'est
pas le même que dans les documents de
cours
il s'agit en fait du numéro de série de
la Range Rover de Clarissa comme on peut
le voir ici à travers son pare-brise
comment un huissier peut-il se tromper à
ce point bonjour monsieur portugais
c'est annulés Canada Pierre-Yves
portugais refuse de répondre à nos
questions il nous renvoie à son patron
son patron c'est Sylvain Gravel l'ancien
président de la Chambre des huissiers je
parle à Monsieur Gravel il refuse notre
demande d'entrevue mais son téléphone il
nous explique pourquoi sa firme a saisi
la mauvaise voiture
on passe à devant chez lui on cherche
une sorte de véhicule on l'a jamais vu
ok on a vu le même modèle de véhicule
avec un autre numéro de série un autre
numéro de plaque qu'on a plusieurs
reprises
qui était très près de l'adresse de la
personne ou la personne restait donc on
s'est peut-être dit c'est de la grâce du
véhicule c'est sans les acheter un autre
ou peu importe la raison là donc on a
fait de vérifier l'eau de véhicule ils
ont eu des confirmations que ça
appartenait de monsieur qui vous a
confirmé que la voiture du monsieur nous
on a fait une césa Société de
l'assurance automobile du Québec les
huissiers n'ont pas accès aux données de
la Société de l'assurance automobile du
Québec impossible pour eux de vérifier
directement qui est le propriétaire d'un
véhicule alors pour tenter de confirmer
l'identité du propriétaire ils envoient
un avis de saisie à la SAQ avec le
numéro de plaque le numéro de série et
le nom de la personne cibler par une
saisie si la demande de saisie est
acceptée par la SAQ ils ont déduisent il
s'agit du bon propriétaire c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait avec la voiture de
Clarissa
si ce qu'on envoie à Société de
l'assurance automobile du Québec et
conforme il traite notre demande
monsieur dessus avec le numéro de série
numéro de plaque tout ça là
parce que ça serait revenu non traité on
aurait pas ses élevé le véhicules c'est
sûr la sac est formelle en aucun cas
elle ne valide l'identité du
propriétaire d'un véhicule visé par
cette procédure cette procédure-là
elle sert à bloquer les transactions
d'immatriculation sur un véhicule c'est
vraiment d'empêcher que quelqu'un
puisse vendre le véhicule de façon
pressée avant que le que le huissier
puisse se dire le véhicules donc c'est
impossible pour un huissier avec cette
procédure-là de valider le nom d'un
propriétaire d'un véhicule
on valide pas le nom ou pas d'un nom sur
le formulaire ça change pas de choses
pour nous parce que nous on valide les
quatre éléments prévus à l'article 730
de procédure civile c'est-à-dire numéro
de notification de véhicule
immatriculation modèle et année de
véhicule est-ce
que les savent qu'une demande de saisie
auprès de la sac ne permet pas de
valider l'identité du propriétaire voici
la réaction de Sylvain Gravel après lui
avoir fait peur de la position de la sac
par courriel la réponse de la SAQ me
jette par terre
bonjour est-ce que je peux parler à
Monsieur Taillefer s'il vous plaît nous
avons interpellé le président de la
Chambre des huissiers François Taillefer
refuse notre demande d'entrevue et voici
ce qu'il nous écrit mon confrère a fait
les démarches appropriées pour vérifier
le propriétaire du véhicule les
démarches sont entreprises auprès de
l'assureur je vais laisser les parties
régler la situation sans mon
intervention
Patrice Deslauriers et professeur de
droit à l'Université de Montréal ici
quand on regarde ça c'est clair que
quelqu'un qui a été fautif mais il faut
aller un petit peu plus en arrière pour
voir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et
peut-être changer cette pratique là si
ils ont mis un risque ils se sont fiés
sur des éléments qu'il ne devraient pas
auquel on devrait pas se fier c'est
préoccupant en tenant pour acquis que
c'est une pratique qui est un peu disons
qui comporte certains risques je pense
que de le faire serait considéré comme
une forte à ce moment-là oui
deux semaines après la saisie Clarissa a
rendez-vous au poste de police
l'huissier doit enfin lui remettre sa
voiture
de l'extérieur bon elle semble ok mais
il faut que je la fasse vérifier
presque deux mois plus tard on a
rendez-vous avec Larissa chez son
concessionnaire sa voiture est toujours
en réparation en attente deux pièces la
remorqueuse semble avoir causé des
dommages ce qu'on voit physique
ça peut forcément
liée
les routes ont pas on peut faire des
dommages le pare-choc avant qui a été
brisé endommagé j'ai une caméra de
stationnement qui est situé à l'avant
aussi qui est endommagé il y a des
pièces qui ont été
abîmé au total jusqu'à maintenant ça
vous a coûté combien cette mésaventure
mais puisqu'il va faire que je règle les
factures de la location et des
réparations payer les frais d'avocat et
c'est environ on parle d'un 10000
dollars
[Musique]
si clarisseur souhaite obtenir une
compensation financière elle devra
intenter une poursuite aussi vide
éprouvée la faute de l'huissier
évidemment il y a une paire de
jouissance du bien si j'ai bien compris
il était peut-être endommagé donc il y
aurait des dommages
purement économiques et également les
troubles les inconvénients là des
souffrances
les pollutions continuèrent par leur
enquête si tout le monde a retrouvé sa
vie moi je suis deux mois plus tard avec
la voiture de location ma voiture est au
garage encore en train de gérer ça
Clarissa à l'intention de porter plainte
en déontologie à la Chambre des
huissiers contre l'huissier qui a saisi
son véhicule elle a aussi envoyé une
mise en demeure à la firme Hainaut
gravelle et si nécessaire elle est entra
une poursuite contre cette ferme